good morning believe nation today's
message is be memorable over to you
Robert Downey jr. if you start playing
violins I will tear this joint apart
first of all I'd like to thank Susan
Downey for telling me that Matt Damon
was going to win so don't bother to
prepare a speech that was at about 10:00
a.m. I don't have anybody to thank I'm
sorry everyone's been so gratuitous it
was the collaboration we all did this
together certainly not gonna thank
Warner Brothers Alan horn and my god
Robin off these guys they needed me
avatar was gonna take us to the cleaners
but they didn't have me we didn't have a
shot buddy what am I gonna do thank Joel
silver the guys only restarted my career
12 times since I began and 25 years ago
I mean I really don't want to thank my
wife because I could be bussing tables
at the daily grill right now if not for
her
Jesus what a gig that it be I never
watch any of the award channels and
speeches and shows because I find them
mostly boring it's one speech into
another speech into another speech
they're all just thanking some people
that I don't know and it's really great
to show gratitude and appreciation but
as a viewer at least for me I find it
super boring and when I look at
businesses most businesses are pretty
boring look at one guy's website against
another girl's website against another
guy's website and they all look the same
they all kind of mold and merge into
this big pile of boring crap that's most
people's company's right
what is so memorable about you that I
want to spread the word that I need to
remember who you are to come back and
buy more from you and tell people about
you right Robert Downey jr. speech
you're gonna love it
you're gonna hate it but you're gonna
remember it and that's what I want when
I'm going to speak in events and I see
the guy before me and he's doing the
typical boring presentation it actually
Jazz's me up like I get fired up when
the guy before me is super boring
because I have to come and bring energy
and I know I can do it and be
different than the guy before me and you
need to do that in your business too and
risk people hating you risk people
giving you negative comments risk people
clicking away from your website or
closing your YouTube video because the
ones who love what you stand for who
love what you're all about
they're gonna be avid fans you want
people to love you or hate you but not
be forgotten you play in that middle
zone you're boring you're blah you'll be
forgotten and when you're forgotten you
can't make money you can't have an
impact you're not gonna reach your goals
so do something to be memorable today
even if it's a little bit scary so the
question they today is what are you
gonna do to be memorable today leave in
the comments below
I'm gonna join the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events better